oh I get too old for bongs dude to over
bond ah okay so we have the same exact
deck in the same exact order so your top
two cards should be ten of clovers and
king of black tears I have club I guess
you say clubs I think clovers tomato
tomahto
and then at king of black tears with
that you mean the Spade what's a spade a
spade like it's like this shape yeah
looks like a black tear well or Hershey
kiss some of these nose that is
weirdly accurate let's deal it out baby
okay I hope we did it right get the king
of black tears and I have a Jokers I
took all the Joker's out of my deck
that's just a rule of my family because
those are like wild and no I had two ten
of clubs
what's clubs clovers right to my day -
my day weekend Timmy ultimate oh wait
who's this Tim milk - Tim Curry Nanny
McPhee Oh none okay yeah let me just
like play solitaire individually and
just tall we can only play solitaire
online because it look like yeah like Oh
cards like come on you know I mean
they're lattice buying things G is it
out yeah uh yeah you just act you know
like what that makes you feel like don't
be mad dude but I just I'm just sitting
here with my vibrator
I'm not vibrating it's on inserted we
had this conversation before about how I
would like to know when that was going
I'm not building up to something this is
not just not have a narrative to it it's
the same as if I had a heating pad I
have a heating pad on the small my back
right now well you're also a pervert and
I think we need a second to think about
this okay I'm really sorry I betrayed
your trust
it's alright I'll prexy in like a little
bit I'm not mad I'm right boy bunny fee
[Music]